change comes in all forms right now it
comes in little pieces big pieces
continuous there's a lot of that the big
pieces which is what I know most about
tend to be still episodic one hits you
then another hit you although the
direction we're going right now is not
only lots of small but more frequent big
changes and that's the direction of
future is going to be
the rate of change very clearly is going
up has been for some time all kinds of
statistics will show that I think the
two big biggest drivers are
technological change and globalization
they produce lots of sub drivers like
competition in industries and the like
and those two are not going to go away
globalization is going to bring us
closer and closer together across
nations and technology you can't stop so
the amount of change is going to I think
in the rate just go up and up and up for
I don't know how long
innovation is kind of a sub piece of
change it's very difficult to innovate
without requiring people to do something
different and whenever you require
people to do something different you're
talking about change so there are lots
of other kinds of change but innovation
is a particularly interesting one right
now especially when you need new ideas
and new ways of doing things to be able
to compete prosper etc